- You also did something
else that's very cool,
so you recently, you
opened the Prada show?
- Yes, that's what you do.
- So, I mean, what?
So, how did that happen?
How did that come about?
- Thank you.
- [Kelly] That's so cool.
Look at you.
- [Amanda] Damn, damn, damn.
- [Kyle] I know.
- Look at that Blue Steel look.
Oh my gosh.
Look at him look at the camera.
Eh!
- There it is.
- I mean, was that so fun?
- One thing is going through
my head, don't fall down.
- [Kelly] Amen.
- Do not trip.
That was really my motivation.
Raf Simons, who's working with
Mrs. Prada, Miuccia Prada,
he's been there for two years now
and he's always liked
my stuff, "Twin Peaks"
and the David Lynch stuff.
- Yeah.
- And he invited myself and
a number of other actors
including Jeff Goldblum,
who's also in the show.
- Oh, I've worked with
him, he's fun, yeah.
- He's lovely.
- Or been on the show.
- He said come to Milan and do this
and I said is it really gonna happen
because of COVID and
everything and it did happen.
And they took such good care of us.
They were so gracious, so kind.
- It's such a cool idea.
- It's so fun.
I mean, it's just like go and
have a good time in Milan.
- Yeah, fine.
- And after that, then you go out
and you eat pasta afterwards.
You don't eat pasta before,
you have to go out afterwards.
- Ah, why I could never be a model.
One of the many reasons.
So wait, so that Prada
video was on your TikTok,
so how does your teenage son,
how does your 13-year-old feel about this?
- Oh, he cringes.
He cringes.
- Oh he did?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- He didn't think at all like that's rad?
- Anything I do on
TikTok, he's like, "Dad,
that's just not cool."
I'm old school so I like
TikTok to be a little nice
and kind of planned out
and I think the thing to
do is you just kind of--
- It's supposed to be kind of--
- Spontaneous, right?
- But they say it's spontaneous,
it's not spontaneous.
You know how many times they did that
before they posted that?
Yeah.
They be lying.
Yeah, yeah, all those people
that are like, "Oh no, wait,
this angle was better."
- Okay, I feel better, I feel better.
Thanks, Kelly.
- [Kelly] It's not you, you're
not cringey, you're awesome.